who's gonna take AJ steps inside in the
comments honestly hello everybody my
name is markiplier and welcome back to
draw 'fl with way Jessie and Daniel if
cyndago he's replaced Brian here and
he's gonna join us here so if you
haven't seen the last episode it's
obviously in the description catch up
with it and it's really cool so we won't
explain the rules this time we're
assuming that you know how this go oh
god
legally dry really oh okay what am i
damn it what could another bet if it
wasn't that oh how is that that 16th
birthday
oh that's just baby I thought it was a
burrito it's a dog like you knew what
that was that's totally yes I drew is
this guests yeah won't you well ok then
young Annie well let's just up my okay
are you just given by yourself over
there we're not laughing at we're just
sad have you've done or said that was
fun you'd be like laughing at a little
child for this horrible thing to be
brought in front of us just forget put
words make it a nice guy I don't laugh
at small children which is why I'm not
laughing at you wait so did you put no
hope there and it's the future of
America else I'll tell you later
hmm cuz I mean what else could it be
how is that bad it's good to say no
hablo this is a B there's no it's not
you can't justify that's what it is
when it's clearly not you're an idiot
you're big idiot
we hate you I mean obviously I'm the
greatest artist here hahahahahahaha oh
do you think there is like a you know
you know some lorem smooth
well I wasn't even think about that I
bet that is that but I mean like a porno
spoof of like regress grown-up thank you
there's a shot why do they have two eyes
on outside of their head there's a shot
now it's like every course on both of
their heads oh yeah I don't know him I
totally thought that was a volcano
erupting I there's the guy with a potato
in the martini glass no that's his
testicles his name is ball for his ball
he'll have a mother
Hey aha gotcha
you did I sure did I did okay
haha no one's dancing it's like it's
like broken oh hey I got something
breaking everything right snap in there
I'm so stupid
my game is dumb and I hate it oh god
what this isn't even a word I'm
something a hollow how exact not your
fault that was that not your fault it's
not oh come on oh no no thanks
Hey and it's handed back up over that
pot it wasn't because of what I did know
what it's bugging us would you draw that
you might you know what you are
absolutely right but oh my god it
doesn't make any sense
oh so stupid
who keeps drawing disco balls something
I worked with what I had you draw from
the same [ __ ] every single time
don't you think I know what all three of
those things are and I have no idea what
they have in common
yeah watch that one I read the entire
know you kill added three letters of
that in my hand oh you'll see Oh God
here's empty Emma ticks
thank you
she's that's what Bell
why would you pick - what he said what
the hell didn't your mother said festive
virus either is Festivus good guess that
I put in a disco ball where's the pole
where so festive I don't know where's
the feets of straight that's mine is all
of your faces our skulls thank you
I know but you picked up by the mics
we're actually we're actually all like
leading we could realize that because
the other ones are so bad yeah I have
you know I've the mood kick you move
that's terrible terrible Janet that was
is that a baby maybe yes then what's the
rest of it um just follow the picture it
was supposed to look better than that it
looks so much better small story of your
face I just didn't have the right
resolution for the enlarged image can I
get some of that okay you actually did
bid their holy all right shoes are
amazing and whoo that was the other
thing out there though the priests a for
sale sign yeah for sure oh yeah
they gave it away because no one was
capable
yeah exactly that's actually really who
who made that quote uh wasn't him anyway
all right hey I win again I'm in the
tough race oh that's donor I thought you
were gonna win for sure you started out
of the gate like with six thousand oh
seven life for myself is good nice
that's nice dude that's nice
okay well that's another episode of draw
phul thank you everybody so much for
watching check out weds channel Jessie's
Twitter I guess he's never gonna tweet
on and Daniel over there from cyndago
they do a lot of music videos sketch
comedy out work with them they're
hilarious thanks again everybody let us
know how we did if you enjoyed this let
us know if you want more definitely if
you want to see more we're gonna do one
more but in the future um no never know
thank you again and as always we'll see
you in the next video bye bye chicken
and rice oh boy okay wonder is this fake
water isn't real blood what should I
fear here